انا اعتقد ان هناك اشياء كثيره يعني
التكثيف النواحي ايضا الجوانب التوعويه
للجيل الجديد ايضا الجيل الجديد لابنائنا
فمثلا في المدارس كنا فتره فترات المدارس
يوم المرور يوم كذا يوم الشجره هناك
الحقيقه الزم علينا في اطلاق يوم يشعر به
الجميع الحقيقه هذا حصل باختصار انا الوقت
الى ماذا تدعو مثلا الى الى غير المظاهر
الاحتفاليه لله الدوله ما انت الى ماذا
تدعو
لتجذر ويترسخ الوعي اعتقد انه لابد ان
يكون هذا على مدار العام وتذكير ايضا
الناس بهذه باهميه المواطنه وايضا اهميه
الاستشعار الناس لوطنه وايضا بيئته وانه
لا غنى عنه هذه الحقيقه مهمه لكن
صناعه محتوى جاد وحقيقي على مستوى افلام
افلام دراما او مسلسلات على مستوى
وثائقيات وايضا مراكز دراسات يحاضر فيها
امثالك يكون على المستوى المحلي بل ايضا
ربما الدوله ايضا السفارات المملكه وايضا
الامور الثقافيه لابد ان تكون هناك يد
واحده في ايضا ايصال هذه الفكره المهمه
لتاريخنا